presented by the boys taking the fight
to superheroes on Amazon Prime video on
July 26th
[Music]
from the studio that's gone from doom
and gloom to fins and grins comes a
fun-filled ride for the kid inside
everyone
just maybe not actual kids he'll the
little girl
Shazaam me billy batson he's got the
street smarts apart Simpson and the
street wear of Tyrone Biggums when billy
gets lured into a cave by an old man who
claims to be a wizard which to be clear
kids is never a good idea
lay your hands missed he'll become one
of DC's classic characters Captain
Marvel no he used to be Captain Marvel
but DC changed it to Shazam
that's Kazaam common mistake I mean the
guy obsessed with being worthy and
lightning no the street rat who gets
wish-fulfillment powers wish-fulfillment
three wishes to be exact okay it's the
one where Chuck flosses
gather round for a heartwarming tale
that out families Fast and the Furious
I'm a big believer in finding family you
don't meet time it could also be
construed as pushing away his family if
a superhero can't save his family he's
not much of a hero thank you for this
family you don't we're in a change of
pace from Marvel's constant daddy issues
we get another installment of DC said
mom parade forgive me for everything if
you choose to leave it may never return
I'm sorry I never told you it's me
sb Lee learns that family isn't about
who abandoned you at a carnival on a
whim it's about the people you're forced
to live with who love you because you're
constantly saving their asses from being
killed
but Shazam we'll have to fight more than
just the overburdened foster care system
he's up against dr. sivana a veteran
character actor out for revenge on DC
for casting him as Sinestro in Green
Lantern watch him unleash the power of
the seven deadly sins each its own
representation of a different human
failing with unique powers that actually
no never mind their own as kind of gray
blob so just eat people man the rock can
not get here fast enough does the next
one really have to be about the very
angry caterpillar follow a question what
so cheer along as DC finally cracks the
code on making a hard warming fun
inspiring movie about an invincible
strong man a super man if you will that
gives kids everything they dream of no
not turning into a 38 year old in a
styrofoam muscle suit no not terrorizing
the boys who make your life a living
hell I'm talking about a kid's ultimate
power fantasy developing a moderate
YouTube ball weighing doing it for the
memes BAE bang smash that like button
shows real story you're a wizard Billy
the movie trying to write the starring
section for us CaptainSparklez fingers
our voice maximum mr. Philadelphia human
power storm frequency flinger zaps a lot
yeah not so easy is it kid chief of
staff see and that's how it's done he is
a villain he came here to stone I bought
from a wizard Burt Ward of the stage
free Teen Titans go an uncomfortable
amount of r.kelly references believe
that you can fly I believe I can fly I
believe I can
make a live-action gargoyles movie you
cowards can we be done with flossing now
please pan through the window through
the wall
[Music]
it's only Sparky in Philadelphia okay
this is the second DC film with an
Annabelle cameo so the conjuring
definitely takes place in this universe
but teasing us with the cameos already
and an Aquaman punch the nun in the face
this episode was brought to you by the
boys a new series on Amazon Prime video
premiering on July 26th your friendly
neighborhood night monkey no more mr.
nice guy the week is long the silver cat
feeds when blue meets yellow in the West